hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to QT now it's been a while
since PT if you remember that game it
was the horror game about the hallways
the game never reached fruition I think
it was supposed to be a new Silent Hill
game that never actually came out but
this is QT a different take on the
concept of PT so let's uh-oh
puck hole there were whoa whoa okay ah
adorable
I was looking was there something to
happen up
okay I thought this was gonna be cute
and adorable
I mean it kinda is alright well oh man
this is bringing me back
this is bringing me way back Oh
everything's happy absolutely even my
crosshair is a tiny smile that's amazing
I love this game I love it already
oh it's horrible but I love it okay cool
all right hey anybody hid in the
bathroom
oh look behind you I don't want
oh I'll be right with you
how are you you good good good to hear
good do uh good to hear how are you it's
good to see you hi I'll just don't mind
don't mind don't mind me just cruisin on
by alright hello are you pop a smile
whoa okay oh it's cute oh it's a plan
with a little smile leaves all right now
it's getting disconcerting at first I
was like uh everything's happy and
smiley and that's that's good that's a
good thing I was like that's a very good
thing but now it's not so good now seems
a little less good that seems ungood
what does that tattoo is that I don't
know what you're staring at ooh hey look
at this look at this everything has a
smile what is that an ant Oh cute it's
the first thing I've said first time
I've said an ant was cute but okay
friend juice
Oh smile phone smile lactis smiler SHhhh
okay it's Billy smiler SHhhh
okay cool odds carry on uh-huh yeah all
right so anything different looks
relatively the psalm a maybe I didn't
make the change happen I think that was
like a part of it you have to actually
make things happen in this you have to
linger long enough in the right spot sir
I don't know I never really understood
how that game worked I just walked
around until enough stuff happened I
guess I'll just go for it I guess oh I
did not know I was supposed to pick you
up I supposed to pick you hop on my back
oh hey oh oh it is the thing you you're
so big oh you grew up I remember when
you're just this little literally two
seconds ago oh okay all right I'll go
around don't mind me okay so I didn't
need to do something I just didn't know
what all right sorry I took your friend
away
sorry about that very sorry sorry about
that sorry sorry oh hey you're
reproducing um I'm not too happy about
that I'm a little little of balloon
ling-ling all right interesting cool
great you keep doing whatever you were
doing wait a minute oh what's that
I don't know how to crouch can't seem to
all right well that's a thing though
what is that it's like a picture of
somebody walking down the street or
something I don't know
that's weird okay whatever I'm gonna
keep going then hope there's not more
ladybugs when I get around okay no more
ladybugs all right how you doing hey how
you doing hey how you doing it did you
break that window I'll do what the whoa
what whoa wait a minute what there's
something there
what well let me add hello Let Me In I
remember this is how a jump scare was
triggered before uh all right well you
know guess I'll just oh wait a minute
wait a minute
oh hi wait a minute have I just not
looked up oh hi hey how you doing hey
that's the cool swinging light you got
there mind if I jump on it
Oh what what oh okay hello hi he's creep
hey how you doing oh yeah the dildo I
know you yeah okay
Wow all right well just uh do a hey tall
guy hey how you doing oh boy you know I
love computers too
hey you're different than everybody else
why okay what is that comfortable
squatting on the stair risking death
fallen over okay whatever that makes
more sense okay all right oh hi goose
Swan duck goose
what are you good hi goose Hey are you
doing goose okay all right see you
around
Oh God creepy okay all right hey are you
running to the skeleton or are you
running away from the skeleton
oh wow the dildo hi I know you all right
well done spiders oh good okay great
great great nice cat that'ss knows are
its mouth okay oh wait it's different
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what we're hang on wait wait but oh oh
there's something up there hang on
there's something up there
what is that there's something up there
[Music]
alright whatever I don't know okay hi
okay good good I don't know what's
happening oh hi a ghost all right okay
what do you got there what is that
oh you're hooking up a router for the
Internet at least I really hope that's
what you're doing okay anyway see a wire
way wire oh [ __ ] oh oh god I can't get
up here wait what's that with a hoodie
there
what is that what am I seeing maybe I
can get over on the window nah
oh this weird Oh weird okay all right
then yes yeah so there's got to be like
secrets lurking behind each level right
okay just because it gives me the same
thing doesn't mean that it's the only
thing right it's got to be like some
other doodads or knickknacks no nook
nook what Oh God every time it does it
hello
are you enjoying a computer tiny lead
you are aren't you oh you're adorable
but I can jump on that wait hang on whoa
what the hell oh my god hello oh okay
whatever I'm off I'm not sure oh whoa
that's weird
okay loop it again how you doing all
right good friend soda
you mean booze hey what are you doing no
get in that bathroom come on there's
people that need their privacy in there
hey what are you looking up at whoa okay
all right
Oh what the hell wait where what what oh
sad face wait is that like some kind of
console war what the hell
whoa
hey bud okay what happens when I put I
put a sad face in the console I don't
know if that's gonna like fundamentally
change this place oh hey this is
different okay
it's a weird way to pet a dog and all
right well that what whatever you do
whatever it is you wanted to do I don't
think I can actually like click on
anything in here all right I don't know
what it does it must just be like random
right it must be because there's no real
rhyme or reason that I'm finding any of
this nonsense all right hey I haven't
been getting achievements find Wien bull
who's weevil deals thanks Wien bull I
don't know what I don't know who we know
is okay we're hey were you taking that
Oh
port portal Oh No okay um none of this
helps me I still have no idea how to get
open this door I still have no idea why
I'm in frog land I have no idea about a
lot of things I'm very confused
hello Oh back in the party huh are you
actually wearing a fish the fish seems
happy but I'm oh hi uh hello how are you
good good great that's that's so weird
that's uncomfy Oh
Oh what the hell whoa whoa whoa what
what what what what what I got it I got
an achievement that's not even listed on
here what what okay all right whatever
ahh this is so weird if it's it's so
weird I'm just trying to check I hate it
when it just goes weird like that
I'm just trying to check all the nooks
and crannies I possibly could
I mean are you weeble who's weeble who's
we bleed whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
closed for now what wait what what
closed for what closed for now what does
that even mean I've never even seen that
before
your new would it be closed for now so
it is changing so dis change you've just
thought a matter of me going through
this thing right I'm not crazy
Emma I might be crazy Hey yeah clothes
for now oh okay all right will you get
on that you fixed that I'll just keep
going through wait wait this is
different what you different I haven't
seen you you okay oh all right Oh
something's different something very
different yeah second I gotta explore
this every time I come into a new one I
gotta explore it maybe not maybe it's
not worth it I don't know that's weird
whoa way why what the heck in hell whoa
hey hey oh goodness gravy gosh okay
that came out of nowhere how you doing
hey how you doing I don't know if I've
mentioned this but in the back of my
brain I was wondering why this ghost
picture was here okay all right well
yeah you uh you done with this portal
Indian he's still working on it he's
still working on the portal okay good
I'll just you know be here ready to die
anything in the bathroom hmm
anything out the window mmm nothing
all right cool good to know good good to
know good to know good to know how you
doing you so good you know what the hell
what wait wait a minute wait a minute a
way dominant way dominant ah what the
heck was that oh hi ah all right you got
friends okay you got friends you got
friends and you got jokes yeah you got
jokes and friends are you so you so
multi-talented hey lady aren't you
worried about this at all all right cool
good no
get you on the flippety-flip all right
back to normal okay I guess maybe why is
this still closed
oh oh oh
what I just wait I'm okay I I swear I've
been through there so many times have I
not gone through that have I not gone
through that have I gone through that
well what am i okay
okay cool great no no okay well I mean
that doesn't help me but now I'm
thinking that there's secret walls
everywhere
some kind of nook and or cranny that I
can get through whoa what what what what
what what are you kidding me okay
what
oh man this is absurd guys this is just
absurd okay wait
all right so hang on let's sick it whoa
whoa whoa whoa
ghosts are cool ghosts are cool
ghosts are cool are you kidding me are
you freaking kidding me
this whole time no this itself is whole
time I have not been able to do that
this whole time I have not I just have
not been able to do that this whole time
there's no way I have not been able to
do that not at all that's not a thing
that I've been able to do that's just
not I have not been able to do that okay
so these are the only things that I can
actually interact with besides the
ghosts are cool one which are it is true
very true so that means that okay wait
well this one's different it doesn't
have a nose everyone everything else has
like a nose or a chin or whatever way
you want to look at it it's gonna nose
or a chin oh no that doesn't have a nose
either okay is there something I'm
supposed to do with this I don't know
okay I'm missing something okay you you
it's a code it's a code it's a code wait
wait smile smile smile okay what if it's
not a nose what if it stupid well I'm an
idiot
that's not a nose it's too it's too
small it's too wait okay
all right hang on wait let me clear this
okay clear it was smile smile smile
smile
[Music]
[Laughter]
I can run now oh oh oh there's secret
room in here too
why are their secret I was trying to
look at this thing okay air or clothes
for now that's fine everything's closed
so what does it matter anyway
alright cool there's no secret cot
there's so many here's another one
there's another one ooh what is that
YouTube dot what is that
alright fine you know what I'm gonna
type that in and let me meet this real
quick commuting that okay here we go
full screen
[Music]
okay oh okay sure
I'm gonna go with sure great any more
secret rooms in here speak now forever
hold your peace
all right there's I I honestly have no
idea how many secret rooms there been
and I just have not seen and there's got
to be a lot just like walls that I just
haven't brushed my throbbing body upon
of computer room again that's bizarre oh
I'm much faster now by the way I am so
much faster can I jump higher too yeah
you think maybe I can leap tall
buildings in a single bound
oh whoa whoa I'm higher
whoa whoa whoa whoa ha oh come on
okay these shoes have got to be good for
something there's something here
there there what's that ah yeah there's
something there oh come on oh crap
come on okay maybe not god damn it
[Music]
oh-oh-oh-oh wait what was that
I just unleashed that I went up wait
wait wait wait oh-oh-oh I'm above I'm
out wait so wait what do I do
from here what do we do whatever it is
I'm out hey I'm out I'm not happy about
it I made it I made it didn't that make
it wasn't there an escape achievement I
thought that was an achievement oh okay
now I don't trust anything that's
anything as closed for now sure yeah
okay all right yeah whatever
whoa okay all right okay yeah this is uh
yeah this is all normal
hey so normal is normal here normal
their normal everywhere normal normal
normal I should probably have like check
for nooks and crannies but there's very
obviously something up here that I'm
supposed to walk towards so I'm gonna go
towards that ah closed for maintenance a
closed for now hi is it ever gonna be
open the answer is probably no okay
anyway I'm gonna go up here it's weird
temple okay hello nice this is this is
uh this is or oh hey how are you doing I
guess we've all lives here
you wave is it open now today do it oh
come on oh I did something wrong didn't
I oh god damn it
ah cry many Christmas whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what what whoa
what wait
these are some nice jellybeans okay
thank you
oh hi
Foom okay okay thank you
okay thank you hi oh I won what I won
what I guess I got all wet
oh okay I did it
what's this what it what what is this
what is this what the hell uh somes here
okay I think I guess I guess that's it
then I don't know what what that's about
but probably just a project of geometry
that didn't get closed up properly um
maybe I don't know okay hey I'm gonna go
now
i'ma go now i'ma go i'ma go I'll leave
I'll think about here right here so
thank you everybody so much for watching
um there's fun disturbing because of our
punitive I just don't trust it but uh
pretty good I like that a lot that was
very fun so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to play this
link is in the description below
apparently this person loves cutie
smiley faces whoever made this it's
mystery but yeah thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to see the
original PT much scarier but this one
was pretty up there in terms of scary
creepiness I'll link it in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always see you
bye-bye
[Music]